hey guys my name is Jeff Smith all today
is the 25th of September and you're
watching games but news for those of you
came to get back to reading destiny
secret treasure cave you'll find
yourself sorely disappointed since
bungee is shutting that down bungee have
delivered a pretty entertaining albeit
obviously fabricated reason for why the
cave is getting called up as a part of
their mini patch today explaining the
hive of the Holy treasure cave have
realized the futility of their endless
assault on Sky Watch and have retired to
lick their wounds and plan their next
attack despite how popular said treasure
cave was Bungie said the plans shooting
at a black hole for hours wasn't quite
their dream for the destiny play
experience the hotfix also includes
tweaks to other various enemy respawn
timers changes to when you can expect to
see n grams drop as well as what you can
earn for dismantling Queens wrath gear
bayonetta 2 may be good enough to earn a
perfect 10 from some publications but
it's struggling to enchant the japanese
market during its first week of sales
there about 39 thousand copies of the
wii u exclusive game have been sold in
its native market that's an awful lot
less than than 138,000 that the original
bayonetta sold in its first week
although that alarm is available on two
platforms ps3 and xbox360 critically the
game is getting some serious positive
attention with Japanese publication for
mitsui giving the title 38 out of 40
while UK publication edge reckoned it
was a perfect 10 as for what's selling
well in Japan super smash brothers for
3ds is still killing it after surpassing
1 million total sales in less than two
days Bayonetta 2 will land on western
shores on October 24 finally if you've
got your eye on sunset overdrive we have
some news on how the game will look and
run insomniac games president Ted Pryce
confirmed that the xbox one exclusive
open-world action game will output at
900p at 30 frames per second prices this
is the biggest game the studio has
created and the
loads to do even off to the end of the
game destiny style but not really he
also brought out that they intend to
sunset overdrive to be a franchise ask
me a question of the day let me know if
you think sunset overdrive is going to
have what it takes to be a franchise and
whether or not you'll be picking up the
game if you're after more bits and
pieces we've got a trailer for The
Witcher 3 on site as well as an
exclusive Q&A with kajima about Metal
Gear Solid 5 that is it for me today
I'll be back same time tomorrow with my
top five stories of the whole week so I
hope to see you then